well let's go to Westminster straight
away to speak to someone who may have a
thing or two to say about that interview
at Labour's Stella Creasy hello thanks
for being with us today hi Sophie now
you just listen to Alan Foster the DP
leader and among other things she said
that she found it distasteful to see
people dancing in the streets after the
abortion referendum that in Ireland
what's your take on that
I'm guessing it's probably quite
different I'm sorry to hear her say that
and now I would suggest that somebody
who intends to go and March with the
Orange Order in Fife at the end of this
month may want to reflect on the value
of making comments about other people's
protests and decision to join people
look the result in Ireland was
overwhelming it was overwhelming in
terms of the impact it will have on the
lives of thousands of women in Ireland
2.5 million women who now have the right
not to be forced to continue an unwanted
pregnancy but it also reflects the
importance of listening to communities
they had to have a referendum there
because they had a constitutional bar on
being able to provide abortion and
obviously we have to see what
legislation now the Irish government
come up with but clearly that will make
a big impact on people's lives and I
just suggested darling foster
criticizing people for feeling that that
is a powerful statement of equality and
liberation isn't the best way forward if
she wants to be somebody who seem to be
listening to her community now you're
taking matters into her own hands here
in Westminster you're planning this
cross party coalition to try and move to
the decriminalization of abortion in
Northern Ireland just explain what it is
you're trying to do yeah actually what
we're talking about is the
decriminalization of abortion for the
United Kingdom this is a United Kingdom
piece of legislation that we need to
deal with called the offences Against
the Person Act that was written 150
years ago in 1861 and makes abortion a
criminal act it's actually a criminal
act across the whole of the United
Kingdom simply 50 years ago we had
legislation that gave exemptions in
England and Wales that puts abortion
into the same category of criminal acts
as rape as child stealing and as blowing
somebody up with gun powder now I just
think in 2018 nobody in the United
Kingdom can support that but what that
means in Northern Ireland is that if you
are right
and you become pregnant as a result of
that and seek a termination you would
face a stronger prison sentence than the
person who attacked you that cannot be
sustainable and indeed I think that's
why the majority of the Northern Irish
opinion polls show us that the public
there would like to see change they'd
like to see the criminal law being taken
out of this a medical law being put in
place they can't do that Arlene foster
cannot write laws on abortion in the
Stormont Assembly if it gets
reconstituted unless we repeal this
piece of UK legislation so actually what
we're doing is being respectful of
devolution but also requiring them to
take action on this because by removing
that piece of legislation there will be
a gap you see you're saying that you're
being respectful for devolution I think
Ireland fossil would probably take issue
with that and the thing about of course
fair referendum in Ireland it was women
who overwhelmingly voted well everyone
obviously and but but women who kind of
overwhelmingly voted to decriminalize
abortion they made the decision for
themselves so why should it be that
politicians and westerns to decide
what's right for people in Northern
Ireland well at the moment the only
woman with any choice over abortion in
Northern Ireland is Arlene Foster and
she cause she's just said in your
interview that she doesn't want to see
people in Northern Ireland being treated
differently to people in the United
Kingdom but by repealing this piece of
legislation we will not write abortion
law in Northern Ireland we will simply
leave a gap that the civil servants and
indeed the Assembly will need to fill
and also frankly I don't see why Arlene
Foster's views should prevent repeal of
legislation that also affects my
constituents you know when I hear the
DUP saying that we shouldn't be talking
about this in the United Kingdom
Parliament
I hear them telling them that they have
more control over what happens to my
constituents than we do about what
happens in Northern Ireland this is
about removing a piece of legislation
rather than imposing a particular law on
Northern Ireland but they do need to
have this debate the vast majority of
the Northern Irish public want a medical
rather than criminal approach to
abortion and I think for Arlene foster
to be the only person making a choice on
that isn't very democratic at all at the
same time though let's be real I mean
your constituents aren't being jailed
for having abortions are they that in
reality people can get abortions
the rest of the United Kingdom really
the people who this will affect our
women in Northern Ireland well but what
my constituents have to do at the moment
is go through a very long process
involving two doctors and actually since
1967 and the abortion act pills have
been invented that allow an abortion
misoprostol so there is a case also for
decriminalization here so that we can
have a process that recognizes the
technology has moved on across the
United Kingdom you know at the moment
three women a day from Northern Ireland
either travel or take those pills and
they buy them illegally and women in
England and Wales are doing this as well
online that's actually not very safe and
in theory they could face a criminal
prosecution this legislation was written
150 years ago
the abortion note rules that we have in
England and Wales have written 50 years
ago it is absolutely right that the UK
parliament asks do we have modern 21st
century abortion laws that it would make
an impact for every UK citizen including
those in Northern Ireland simply makes a
case for each nation and being able to
describe what a modern abortion law
looks like okay now I can't let you go
without asking you a quick question on
brakes it feels like we always have to
but I was just talking to Barry Guardian
earlier on the show and he was defending
our Labor's position on staying in a
customs union with the EU but leaving
the single market saying that that would
allow goods to be traded
easily with the European Union are you
comfortable with Labor's position on
brexit I've been a member of the Labour
Party for 25 years I've been involved in
campaigns within the labour movement
because we are a democratic member led
movement one of my predecessors as a man
called climatically and he said that the
members of what make it of the labour
party and sometimes with one argument
sometimes we've lost them there is
clearly a difference of opinion about
what our approach to brexit should be
but we're also a democratic movement so
I think it is right that people have
less say stand up and say what they
think is right where things are I have
campaigned I stood at the election and
said very clearly I was going to fight
to stay in the single market because I
could not see a better option not just
for my constituents but for my country I
also happen to think that the final deal
and the decision about whether that is
the best thing for Britain shouldn't be
my choice alone there is a debate to be
had and I hope that Barry will engage
with that in the spirit that all of us
are that we're a political movement they
should be able to talk about
these things take a decision together
look at the facts look at the evidence
okay I don't think anybody can look at
brexit in the last two years and think
it's going swimmingly so it's right that
we say to our members it's right we say
to the country is this the best deal
that meets our values is this going to
be a way that we tackle austerity this
way we're going to bring prosperity I
don't think a hard breaks that will do
that I certainly think staying in the
customs union in the single market is a
better way towards that but you know
what I'm also a Democrat and I think the
public should have their say too